right now i want to talk about a dear
friend who has taught me so much about
food and cooking over the last three
years she's also a part of the drew crew
which is an amazing group of our show's
contributors alumni if you will let's
take a look at the best of chef pilar
valdez
she's a culinary goddess a woman who
deserves a thunderous standing ovation
my culinary partner in crime she's my
dear friend it's chef pilar valdez
today we're making a peppery steak
with an agra dolce sauce let's do it so
we're gonna start with this new york
strip over here okay for this recipe the
reason why i love the new york strip is
because it's tender like a filet and it
has the flavor and fat just like a rib
eye so the first thing we're going to do
is season up the steak really really
well and then you park that for like an
hour and let it sit okay we have some
freshly crushed black peppercorns you're
gonna lay that on your plate or on top
and you're gonna
press down to adhere so we've seasoned
off both sides and meanwhile
you want your pan
heating over medium to medium-high heat
when your pan is nice and hot you're
going to add some oil and right here
actually we have a steak that has been
searing so it's nice and hot time to
turn it over yeah i like to look at that
beautiful
so
this recipe is going to cook stove top
for six minutes but just make sure
you're doing essentially the same amount
of time on both sides same amount of
time on both sides and we're going to
finish this steak in the oven okay
basically um one thing to look for
when you're going into the oven it's
definitely use an oven thermometer so
we're going to make the agra dolce sauce
real quick we're going to dump
everything in that's two tablespoons of
shallots
two tablespoon shallots all that roughly
chopped cranberries wonderful
and then that is my balsamic over there
some water and then we're going to do
some honey so all you have to do is
basically bring this to a boil and then
simmer it for four minutes until it
nice and thick and the last little thing
is off the heat we're going to pour in
our mustard all right so we actually on
the side drew have a steak beautiful
steak that has been resting critical
piece to cooking steak rest your meat
for at least 10 minutes so the last
thing to do is just spoon some of that
beautiful sauce on
oh this cuts yeah
i guess
it is really really good
for today a quinoa risotto
with winter squash seared mushrooms and
fresh herbs shall we jump in yes we
shall okay so the first thing you're
gonna do is actually roast your squash
and you're gonna roast them at like 400
for about 20 20 to 30 what i like to do
is actually cut the squash into chunks
like this drizzle some olive oil salt
and pepper
stick it in the oven 20 to 30 let it go
and then you're gonna take it out and
we're actually gonna make a puree so
you're gonna take the chunks and let's
pop that in the blender lovely and then
you're going to have some stock actually
oh
there you go a little bit of vegetable
stock here we go
yeah baby
lovely so in the meanwhile we had some
of our quinoa going what i like to do is
i start toasting it first in a dry
skillet it adds this really nice
nuttiness to the dish i have to say i've
not
seen people do that yeah and it's really
lovely 45 seconds in a hot dry pan dry
dry that's the key don't put the oil in
it no no oil no nothing and then you're
gonna add some liquid into that we use
vegetable stock and you're gonna bring
that to a boil and then turn it down to
simmer and you're gonna mix it and stir
it and cook it for about 18 minutes so
we're going to take our puree
you're going to take them great which
i've broken
in it feels like a hug in a bowl is what
i like to say which is i love a hug in a
bowl
am i going to start arranging yes please
arrange a range away and with our
trumpet mushrooms they are trumpet
mushrooms i love mushrooms i'm excited
to bring what should be a really heavy
heavy
dish to this lightness that is so
healthy and good for your body but still
gives all of that satisfaction so thank
you delicious for the satisfaction baby
i love you love you they taste like
peanut butter and with the salt on top i
mean
oh my god
this is a true original just like you
pilar thank you
i love you i couldn't do it alone i
could only do it with pilar
oh i love you polar so much we'll be
right back
[Music]
you